I used to live my life a quarter mile at
a time but things changed my father now
I will always be in your heart
little Brian I have a gift for you
your daddy gave me this no I'm gonna
give it to you it's very special it's
for protection from what's coming
all right down it's next no matter how
fast you walk
to be Confed to you knowin are
unsurpassed
crying your vegetable tummy and mine
just caught up to me been a long time
down so we're up against a master thief
assassin high-performance driver
who is he
[Music]
Jacob is Tom's brother your whole life
you pushed yourself to be faster than
Donna smarter than God stronger than Tom
but could you kill him
because I'm ready if you are
there's nothing more powerful than the
love of family but you turn that into
anger there's nothing more dangerous
maybe this is begin but we won't go out
together
you know I'd ride to the death with you
[Music]
[Applause]
it's good to work please tell me that's
not a pontiac fiero strapped to a rocket
engine impressive I know no no that's
that's not impress
I came here to take you down little
caught that that's you're mistaken
this is my world
damn they got a magnet plane hold on
tell me you're not thinking what I think
you're thinking there's no bridge
LLL not
hey guys
surprise nice Clubhouse